the media finding new ways to defend and
excuse the surge in anti-Semitism Hamas
sympathizing ghouls have been ripping
down posters of innocent Israelis being
held hostage but the New York Times
wants you to consider the feelings of
the vandals quote removing the posters
has quickly emerged as its own form of
protest a release valve and also a
provocation by those anguished by what
they say was the Israeli government's
mistreatment of Palestinians in the
Years
before October 7th and since the bombing
of Gaza began I'm going to throw up
another Outlet actually claims that the
posters could be a trap and are baiting
people into getting filmed and doxed and
with garbage like that floating around
it probably won't be long until the
left-wing press finds a way to normalize
the Cornell student who threatened to
kill any Jewish student he saw on campus
the feds arresting 21-year-old Patrick
die for making online threats and he was
in federal court to face the charge
which could land him in jail for up to 5
years the White House getting asked
Point Blank if stuff like that is
domestic terrorism the people in this
country making violent anti-semitic
threats are they domestic
terrorists I I don't uh know that we're
classifying people as domestic
terrorists for that I mean I that's
really a question better left to law
enforcement I'm I'm not aware that
there's been such a a characterization
of that terrible question of course uh
you're not a domestic terrorist if
you're not a white guy in a red hat
that's the rule all right Dana my theory
on why they're defending these people
that are tearing down the posters is
because the truth of the posters is too
hard to bear and it blows it blows your
filter of Oppression versus oppressor
filter right out of the water it
shatters your ego if you're on the other
side so I think what they're saying is
is like it's just is too hard to look at
so get rid of it it's it's so hateful I
mean they would't they they walk by so
many other things that they could tear
down but they don't they decide to tear
down the pictures of children and
earlier today or yesterday I did a an
interview of Martha mcum on her own
podcast because she last week was at the
Israeli consulate and she was part of a
small group of journalists who was shown
the 45 minutes of the Hamas GoPro videos
and the other videos that were put out
okay so it's um her podcast is called
the untold story it posted today it's
definitely something that we should all
listen to she watched it and other
journalists have watched it on our
behalf but they're the witness and she
is shaken up by it of course she is and
what is shocking is that how quickly you
could go from being horrified but what
happen on October 7th to tearing down
posters and you think that's okay and
let me tell you about Alexandri kazio
Cortez ilhan Omar and Rashida TB get
this anti-semitic label M but AOC is
giving them a real run for their money
today she went after
APAC meanwhile she has all of these
incidents happening in her very own City
and she doesn't say a word remember when
there was crimes against women in the
city or asian-americans she says nothing
no but she will defend them no she
doesn't she doesn't do anything for
women in her constituency um uh Jesse
there's another reason I think that
they're defending these people is that
they got exposed they're being filmed so
now now they get away with it would make
a big deal but now the media has to
defend them because they they could get
in
trouble I want to say something about
Arab Americans and about the Muslim
world I'm not going to hold your hand
even though I should
Dana we and when I say we I mean the
west and Western technology have
created the Middle East we made them
Rich we got that oil out of the ground
our military protects all of these oil
shipments flying around the world making
them Rich we fund their military we
respect their kings we kill their
terrorists okay but we've had it we've
had it with them Obama Trump now Biden
have tried to get the heck out of that
stupid desert just as we're about to get
out because we have this great balance
of power we're arranging these crazy
Muslim Fanatics come in and Massacre
over a thousand of our allies and hold
Jewish people hostage hold Americans
hostage and so if you're an Arab
American in this country and you rip
down posters of Jewish hostages of
American hostages
no no no no someone is going to get
punched in the face when you rip down
posters of hostages like that this is
absolutely not and the New York Times
the second sentence Greg that I thought
was even worse who suffering should
command public attention and sympathy so
what they've done is they've now made
suffering a commodity they'll put a
price tag on emotional suffering you
know is it is it the Jews uh is it black
teens the Native Americans the pales you
know who suffered the most and he who
suffered the most is allowed as you say
a free punch and so now they've
Justified Violence to avenge suffering
and so now people are above the law
people are below the law and that's
making everybody crazy because we can't
live in a country like that and and I
won't live in a country like that do you
imagine I mean like I was just thinking
about this that you can burn the
American flag and generally people just
dismiss you as a nut God forbid you
burned a Palestinian flag oh God forbid
yeah you would be you I think you would
be arrested I don't know I don't know
not that I'm advocating that of course
I'm against burning anything except my
Burning Love for Harold Ford how are you
good to be back how great is it to be
back around the table it's tremendous to
be back I've been watching every day and
I'm I'm glad to be able to contribute my
put my voice as a part of this I I don't
necessarily disagree with what Jesse has
said but I think both parties uh in
every organization and company has its
share of Fools and haters and bigots uh
and we're seeing a lot of that on
display now I think sometimes when we
try to have serious conversations
particularly in politics really anywhere
it gets reduced sometimes to I'll be
simplistic uh the progressives or Maga
when really things are far more
complicated political issues I think in
more Nuance in many ways and deserve
more in inspection two I'm always amazed
in the last two weeks as I hear people
in my party the Republican parties I
hear people on college campuses or
elsewhere serious people seemingly say
that they want to ceasefire some sort of
pause but not before or at any time
saying they wish we'd give wish that uh
Hamas would give back the hostages you
can't have a pause or pause or ceasefire
uh until the hostages are given back
it's hard to even it's you can't even
take people like that seriously let
along credibly if they're not willing to
talk about those kinds of things two the
Israeli Saudi normalization which we on
path to getting we have to remember a
huge part of that as as all of us know
was a two-state solution uh something
that would give the Palestinians
predictability stability a chance and an
ability to raise their kids with the
kind of security that we all wish for
our kids uh and this has derailed that
in in in in the worst of ways uh I'd end
on this point which I don't mean to be
political on but I do think we have to
acknowledge that in politics as Kellan
and I both know and all of us know and
Dana knows perhaps more than any having
worked in a White House along with
kellyanne that you can't let the perfect
be the enemy of the good uh Senators
McConnell Graham President Biden they
agree on something that is fundamental
to where we sit right now let's fund
Ukraine Israel let's fund the southern
border efforts and let's fund our
efforts in Taiwan it may not be the
perfect bill it may not may not be the
perfect proposal but we can't wait three
to four weeks to get this done so I
would hope that those who want to solve
this want to be a part of the solution
be a part of the solution uh and and
stop being a part of hindering things
that's on college campuses and in our
Congress that that solution though of
grouping things together is always just
infuriating to me not you're not
infuriating to me you never will be but
this the idea of having to put these
things all together what do you think
kellyan well House Republicans are
pushing back on that it's a big question
back in their districts people don't
want all those funds comingled they
don't want to think of this as as one
big thing but I want to get back to the
Chiron we looking at liberal media
defend people ripping down uh hostage
posters uh people should know that
President Biden said well I don't really
have confidence in Hamas numbers and the
Washington Post fact Checker Glenn
Kessler said you know they Hamas has a
pretty good track record at revealing
death tolls defending them yet again the
New York Times calling this a release
valve that if you're ripping down
posters of Israeli hostages which you
correctly point out and must be returned
it's a release valve they're not jogging
boxing or having shot of tequila I mean
so even these subtle phrases that
somehow pass an editor or two's desk
that are somehow reporting facts to the
rest of us and I would like to point out
in 2021 he did it the first time but in
2023 at Howard University President Joe
Biden said that white suprem Y is the
most dangerous thing in the United
States of America that's what he said
you can't even get John Kirby to say
that this is domestic terrorism people
who are ripping down posters and I have
to say what's going on right now the
calls for ceasefires the pramas
sympathies that's not just young people
on college campuses that's Democrats in
the halls of Congress 18 of them just
last
Thursday signed a resolution calling for
the quote immediate deescalation and
ceasefire in Israel and quote occupied
Palestine so if you've got 18 Democrats
all of whom are Hispanic and
African-American exactly the kinds of
folks that Joe Biden is going to rely
upon to help him win again and they're
they are raging him the New York Times
had a whole article it said young and
diverse left rages at Biden so this is a
big problem for the party I I appreciate
you trying to make it bipartisan I I
don't think it well I don't think
anybody should I I think there should be
no question everybody should condemning
AOC said today APAC is a terrorist
organization calling for violence
bipartisan organizations that's who goes
on trips with them in N DC yes they take
everyone over there maybe you've gone I
haven't but we all we all need to know
that somehow the media Weeks Later Greg
still can't get this right they can't
figure out and I think that mainstream
media is edging toward immoral Clarity
on all of this yeah and when you're
you're seeing Jews now in New York
protecting the posters how soon will New
York Times call them instigators hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else